he's Frank Vogel the orlando magic head
coach she was fired as the head coach of
the Pacers back on May 5th he joins us
with her Continental Tire coaches corner
coach good morning how are you good want
to have Patrick how you doing good sir
let me ask you about this home court
advantage because Toronto is really good
at home and then they go to Cleveland
and they're terrible how does that
happen at you go an hour and all of a
sudden you're a completely different
team yeah I don't know if I've seen that
you know this much of a contrast in
home-home play versus your road play in
any playoff series it's a little unique
you know obviously teams are gonna play
better at home and what comfortable as
behind them noradrenaline you know it's
just tough for a play on the road but
you know I think this is a unique
situation where the contrast is so great
have you ever had a great speech and a
half time when you're down big um yeah
sure you know sometimes you do light let
you guys up a little bit and uh you know
sometimes not always about you know
getting into your guys but you know hey
we gotta make some tactical adjustments
you know and when we do this you know
the second half is all for going to be
better than the first so um you know
sometimes it's about your fire sometimes
it's about your your strategy certainly
there's been times where you know a half
hour speech wasn't very good have you
ever known a job I felt like that
impacted it have you ever done said
anything at Hampton uh not not nothin
you know I think there's some times
where you know we come in and you know
we might Michael a couple days with you
you know what we really really have to
do you know we know that to do Jay's
gotta do it flips I don't do it we're
not gonna win you know but I don't think
I've ever come in and just said nothing
because that would really mess with him
coach where you just come in and go I
you you disgust me and then you just
walk out or you just look at me you just
walk out shaking your head yeah I've
done that before
talking to a venal Orlando head coach
Frank Vogel let me look before we look
ahead let me look back do you look back
on Indiana and say if I had only done
this or we'd only done that I'd still be
employed there well I think if we won
Game seven I probably still still be
there but i like i like that chances
with some of the other matchups but you
know you can't really second-guess
things like that and you do you do the
best job you can and you let's just fall
where they may and very proud of the
body work what we had in indianapolis
and with the Pacers all six years that I
was there as head coach and you know it
was a I guess the chain was needed and
I'm looking forward there's no
opportunity now but you also look at
style everybody wants to copy what you
know the the great teams are doing
whether it's in football the way the
Patriots do it basketball with Golden
State can you actually change your style
and is that the style that everybody is
going to go to because of Golden State
success I think you can definitely
change your style I think your team's
identity and style players is predicated
on the strengths and weaknesses on the
roster you know and obviously you have a
style of coaching that you're
comfortable with and you know you want
to emphasize certain things on the
offensive end defensive then what's
important to you your team will become
what you emphasize but um you know I
think you know my mindset is you know
you can't go out and try to be going to
state when you don't have bone stays
personnel now that doesn't mean you
can't take some of the ways that they
play and you know they're quick strike
offense and how they space and the the
the switching flexibility that they play
with it doesn't you can't take some of
those things and you know apply it to
your team you know where you know in
situations where you have the personnel
to do some of those things i think i
will definitely having most coaches are
trying to do some of that but we're not
trying to become the Golden State
Warriors obviously what is Oklahoma City
doing to Golden State you know to be
honest I haven't watched all the games
but you know I know they're playing
playing big and I trying to impose their
style of play on on the Warriors you
know I know they're doing a lot of
switching which is take
way some of the ball movement that
Golden State has and they're going to
live with uh with some isolation I
simply was going state has excelled at
you know in burning match ups like that
and you know they're gonna try to pick
up boys a little bit and live with some
of that stuff you know but I think
they're just they're understanding the
challenges in front of them you know
you're playing against a 73 win team the
best best team in the history of regular
season basketball so you know you're
gonna have to reach in a league level
and and they're fighting it would you
rather avoid golden state oklahoma city
or cleveland well right where i rather
avoid them yeah if you had to play like
let's say next round that you could
choose who you want to face who would
you choose yeah i'll say what there's
just three heavyweights you know me
personally i'd probably avoid lebron
james i haven't had a lot of a special
bond james thought i might choose him is
there a way to you know go is there a
game plan for LeBron of course there's a
game plan for everyone and you know
obviously I've got great experience and
plan against him so you know there's not
enough time and is this interview to go
to go over all that stuff but it's
really about getting you know being
strong on the ball with him and making
sure that uh you're very very sharp with
your helps and you're helping to help
her because you want to best malaya get
reading help defense when he gets into
the lane and gets penetration you know
and they're just leaving what helps come
from and using his elite passing reaches
is amazing to pick you apart tougher to
defend Steph Curry in LeBron James hi
it's at all come on coach know it's
there a time you gotta pick size I don't
have to pick side I got a plague is both
yeah well you're gonna face LeBron more
than you will steph curry yeah this is
true but on the night that I place you
don't want anything in the level echoes
I know you'll have high expectations but
the expectations of management in
Orlando has to be a little different
than Indiana you didn't get to you
didn't win
you know Game seven and it cost you your
job in orlando those expectations are
lowered a little bit i would imagine is
that is that fair to say i don't know i
think this group is ready to take a big
step and I think everybody miss this
organization kills the same way so you
know I think I think their expectations
are higher this coming year than they've
been I personally want them that way and
I want our guys believing that we're
going to take a big step and we're going
to be a playoff team next year we're
going to build something on the court
that's gonna lend us to believe it we're
going to ask your chest in the playoffs
I believe that I can give it give that
to this team I believe we have the
personnel to do it and I'm looking
forward to get started with these guys
do you have kids Frank I do how did it
go over that you're selling Orlando to
your kids well I've grade 12 and 10 year
old daughters and they're very rooted in
Indiana with a lot of friends you know
they're going to be that they're they're
upset about having to leave them but you
know my thing with this is you know if
we had to leave Indiana where we're so
happy let's find someplace that is a
good place to continue my basketball
journey in a good place where my family
to see as a landing spot and you know
they have have the world of disney and
right around the corner for us is
definitely appealing as a warm weather
this is an attractive place to live so i
really think my daughter is going to
love it down here they see that you know
but obviously it's a tough Buffett yeah
but they're gonna get to that point
where they hate dad or dads you know the
debt they don't dad doesn't understand
them so you're right on the verge of
getting that I think with once they get
to 12 13 14 all of a sudden no matter
what you say or do it's not going to be
the right thing right well bucking that
trend I you know my relationship my
daughter's is special and that's not
gonna happen really yeah good luck with
that good luck coach yeah I felt the
same way with my three daughters and
then they look at your side every bad
yes yes a congrats good luck in Orlando
and thank you for joining us thanks dad
take care the Dan Patrick show we
de mornings on audience